hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today I am doing a very very very highly
requested video I've been avoiding doing
this but every time I post a video about
anything you guys want me to do of
what's on my Apple watch video I never
really thought about doing it because I
feel like I don't really use that many
apps on here so I'm gonna slip this into
kind of two different categories the
first part is gonna be the apps that I
use most and number two will be just all
the apps that I have on my watch
currently this is usually the watch face
that I use the number one thing that I
use this for surprise is to tell the
time I also use it for scheduling
because I can just do a quick little
glance and I can see what my day looks
like if I have a call or a meeting
everything is right there and easily
accessible I also really like this watch
layout because it gives me a lot of
information all in one screen I have
news I have my workouts I can also see a
photo it'll tell me what I have to
breathe and it'll tell me tomorrow's
events plus the current weather another
thing that I really use my Apple watch
for is the fitness tracking if I'm on a
hike even though I don't have watch it
was five so I can't really track that
yet I love being able to track my
fitness activity because it also
sometimes then turns into a competition
with my sister or my friends so if
you've allowed some of your friends to
view your activity they can give you
comments any time you complete something
so it's definitely fun and encouraging
if you are one of those competitive type
people looks like Adam has completed his
goal 113 percent my sister's husband
Brian breeze Brian I haven't changed
that since before they got married
he clearly stopped wearing his IDI 70%
Jenna 99% she's so close Matt he must
have lost his me oh yeah I am a hundred
and thirty three percent
Nathan seventy-eight Nick ninety-six
great job guys seems like all my friends
are on track I also really love the
notifications on this because sometimes
I'll have my phone in my pocket or in my
purse
so I don't always need to get my phone
out I can take a quick glance I feel
like I'm selling you guys on the Apple
watch but really this is what everybody
does so this is all not new information
I'm just telling you how I use it which
I'm sure a lot of you guys use it very
very similar and if you don't please
tell me what do you guys use your Apple
watch for I love being able to just
glance very quickly see if it's
something that I should get my phone out
especially if I'm on set and I'm not
really supposed to have my phone or if
you're anywhere working a job where they
make you put your phone away this
basically doubles as a phone so recently
I've been doing a lot more fitness
activities and I've been hiking a lot
and now that it's
summer the weather has been fantastic
but during the summer I do feel so much
more motivated to go outside and do
things so in the past couple of months I
have been hiking and I like to keep my
phone in my pocket so if I don't have
access to it I can control my music or
my podcasts or my audiobooks right for
my watch
this is the last audio book that I
listen to so you guys know what is about
to come up but let me just tell you if
you have never got an audible book off
with my promo code before this is the
time to do it now even if you already
have I definitely recommend this book
especially if you're a creative person
you can go to audible.com slash Ida
Steen or text iJustine to 500 500 to get
a 30-day free trial and also a free book
this book it's called big magic creative
living beyond fear now I feel like this
is one of those books that I was
desperately needing to listen to this
whole past year has been a little bit of
a struggle creatively and personally and
just so many different things and I
found that about this book because
Elizabeth Gilbert the author of this
book who also wrote Eat Pray Love which
is crazy I've never read I've never seen
a movie and I didn't even know anything
about it but Elizabeth came and spoke to
us in New York when we were at the
creator summit and she had so many wise
and inspirational things to say so I
just recently finished this book while I
was on a hike and I love listening to
audiobooks especially now that it's in
the summer just going out hiking being
alone and listening to a book especially
this one Elizabeth reads it it's only a
five-hour lesson so it is fairly quick
so it Elizabeth says in the book this is
by far one of my most favorite quotes
I'm kind of summarizing it the older
that I get the less impressed I am with
originality and more impressed with
authenticity if you like this quote is
so powerful especially to a lot of
people here on YouTube we lose ourselves
in that vicious cycle of just making
more videos and not being ourselves so
hearing that quote and having that just
sort of reiterate everything that I've
been doing in the past couple of years
looks so powerful and so meaningful and
I just really hope that if you guys do
get this book that it also has an impact
on you as it has on me
so Elizabeth if you're watching this
with Jeremy you're probably aren't I
just want to say I love you you're
incredible and thank you so much for
inspiring me and inspiring so many other
people next on my list and list is Eat
Pray Love again if you want to get a
free book and a 30-day free trial go to
audible.com slash iJustine or text
iJustine to 500 500
so I want to go through the rest of
these apps that I have on here and this
is something that I just recently
learned I didn't even realize that you
could do this I feel so silly because
this is something that I feel like I
should know I'm I just Dean and I didn't
know this I know I'm Chuck here's all my
apps if you do a hard press it'll change
to a list of you so here in list view
you can go through all of your apps so
going through these we have activity
Airbnb alarms American Airlines the
Apple Store British Airlines flights
breathe calendar camera Fandango
find friends fly Delta GoPro headspace
health mate heartrate home Hieu JetBlue
Lou Flynn's uh I always mispronounced
that airline mail maps so one of the
things that I do like about Apple maps
is if you are driving it'll kind of give
you that little extra notification of
hey you're gonna be turning now make
sure you do that messages Facebook
Messenger music MyFitnessPal which I
haven't used in quite a while
News phone photos radio realtor.com
which I don't even remember ever
downloading that reminders remote
settings Starbucks stocks stopwatch
swarm timer tweet bot uber United wallet
weather workouts I'm extremely excited
if I haven't mentioned it already for it
to be able to track yoga and hikes I
can't wait world o'clock Yelp and Zillow
so those are all the apps that I have on
here there's only been a few moments
where I've actually forgotten my Apple
watch at home and it's always just I
just feel like something's missing
I get so used to doing this being able
to just look at my notifications and
know everything that's going on with my
day and it's also very strange because I
start getting phantom
taps on my wrist when I don't have it
and I wear this thing so tight I've
gotta get a permanent indentation and a
tan line I really need to maybe switch
up my wrists a little bit so that I can
get this tan line even now I've been
looking at a bunch of mock-up designs
that people are saying that this could
be the next Apple watch I definitely
think that they are probably gonna make
it a little bit thinner because this is
kind of I mean it is a little bit thick
it really hasn't changed in size for
quite a while
thankfully this
here I realized that I should not be
wearing a 42 millimeter watch it always
felt a little bit big but I thought that
I wanted a bigger screen and when I
switched to the 38 it was honestly
shocking what a difference I made I
really love my Apple watch and I
honestly just feel like it is such an
extension of me now I'm very excited
about the future of Apple watch and I
can't wait until they announce something
new because I am just like patiently
waiting I'm also still patiently waiting
for air power I just want to be able to
charge all of my devices at the same
time on one beautiful little mat I need
this I need this in my life let me know
if there's any other videos you guys
would like to see me make here I've been
taking a lot of your suggestions and you
guys have so many incredible ideas and I
love being able to make those videos
come to life for you and again if you
guys do decide to get the book big magic
by Elizabeth Gilbert please let me know
what you think about it after you read
it or listen have her read it to you I
have been packing and getting ready for
VidCon
which is happening like right now like I
should be packing but I'm shooting a
video and now I'm gonna go edit this and
then I'm gonna pass so I'll see you guys
there and I think this is probably a
good time to maybe start Eat Pray Love
Elizabeth you're the best you guys are
the best I will see you in my next video
thank you I watched the best
[Music]